hello and welcome to co playing bronze
storm let's into opponent never played
him before and so let's see what is
coming up with early f5 stuff yeah
Bishop with seven is Nolan now check
let's see okay this is also playable but
usually um unbelief to be a bit better
for white white has good control you
with d5 in particular the Queen will
come to d2 now therefore B 3 B should be
true these are the next moves and black
am not quite clear what blacks active
planners so maybe this first probably
doesn't matter that much okay so this is
interesting just 95 is good I put it
this one for night b5
okay this is part of whites build up
anyway so this is why I did this room I
mean III is Sun something I like to do
anyway might be five what's this let's
think about this for a moment might be
five c6 takes takes out the system
assistance is good huh
now he has issues on c78 796 it's not
easy for me to play the C porn with the
bishop on g 2 1 105 so okay so I'm go
back here attacking f5 taking f5 why can
I not take it and I think I can take it
yeah playing the English opening at the
moment all the time yet I really get
fantastic positions I mean people really
seem to have problems fighting it
ok so how to do this now should p.m. no
I think just pile up on the C file and
can i when I'm wondering wat f380 for I
should do that now I'm not sure about it
but this is also my bad keeping more
control over a 4 and doubling on the C
file I mean Luke's the eighth i have
bishop age three so this is not such an
it's not so easy defended I just prepare
suks eh I guess but i have before right
Bishop d7 I will take and where's he
going just back
okay so all the way back I guess and now
f45 should be should be the most direct
way of doing it here
black resins and two points short at two
points short to 498 okay so i was a bit
of an opening disaster to be honest I
think that this this kind of structure
here after default take squint eggs with
the f porn being played is pretty bad
for black it's a it's maybe not like a
clear advantage for white but White's
play is so much easier check I can just
easily centralized put stuff towards t5
and black just has an inferior structure
yeah this was getting very annoying
already the computer wants to play
Bishop takes d5 and that tells you that
something is wrong ever t he gave me
even more like okay could've played
there for but anyway this is already
very good k the engine actually wants to
know group do you want okay but that's
not bad I was thinking yes to place his
six and then I would have taken check
and gone back and it should be better
and this is these are weak but this is
probably even more problematic okay then
he gave me that pawn and this is
fantastic position under there the
bishop pair no yeah I think em black has
to reconsider the opening concept I
don't really think that this is leading
to a good position what black definitely
can play as soon you can play Bishop to
e7 does this kind of position is
playable because this is check not all
that bad dad's it's a playable position
for black okay well thanks for watching